c'est pour ou contre le bizutage au long
du week-end d'intégration puisque le
bizutage est interdite mais voilà on a
compris ses week-ends d'intégration
ces bizutages est ce que vous êtes pour
ou contre qu'on sait très bien que dans
ses week-ends d'intégration
il y à du bizutage très souvent alors
vous vous êtes pour vous vous êtes
contre eric naulleau ce sera le dernier
match de ce soir et ce qu'eric naulleau
va être le grand champion et qui va
remettre son titre en jeu la semaine
prochaine où est ce que eric aubin qui
est magnifique sur cette photo aurait à
ouidah grave alors franchement mercredi
qu il était patron de lci là vous avez
une mauvaise nouvelle
non mais c'est arrivé est-ce qu'il est
toujours souriant lui est normalement la
semaine dernière déjà j'avais une photo
si oui à temps mais ce n'est jamais la
même
non non c'est plat pied lancé l'arrière
salle atlas et il venait de rater venait
de rater le permis de conduire à l'ailé
cheryl 1h19 on est en direct pourront
compte une minute trente pour avoir vos
arguments et nos deux invités nous ont
rejoint puisque tristan organise des
week-ends d'intégration et je sais qu'il
ya des bizutages dans ses week-ends et
solène nous racontera les romancières
nous racontera son bizutage traumatisant
lors de sa scolarité attention c'est
parti on va démarrer par notre champion
inquiets contre c'est eric naulleau
c'est parti ben oui en effet en fait ce
week-end d'intégration c'est le mot
politiquement correct pour bizutage
oui et en général je suis moi je suis
allergique totalement parce que en
général c'est l'autorisation donnée à
des gens généralement avinés de libérer
les plus bas instincts humains
c'est-à-dire le sadisme l'effet de meute
contre les contre les individus seuls et
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer tout ce qui
ne ferait pas dans la vie courante et
qu'il est choquerait l'espace d'un week
end s'ils croient autorisés
vraiment c'est il ya des traditions qui
sont très belles qu'il faut conserver là
c'est une tradition haïssable qu'il faut
abolir et qu'il faut combattre avec la
dernière énergie bord eric raoult raille
eric naulleau comme d'habitude et dans
l'emphase peu caricatural
non moi je trouve ces visas par une
formidable moment en fait un formidable
moment pour des gens qui se retrouvent
qui intègre une école alors il ya sans
doute des excédents vous parler mais de
grâce pas de caricature il ya aussi
plein d'endroits où ça se passe
extrêmement bien
le vrai moment de défoulement à mon sens
et vous posez la question vous montrer
que c'est caricatural si vous venez de
dire mon cher hic c'est que dans un
carnaval quand on met un masque
précisément et peut se défouler on n'a
jamais eu ce débat sur le carnaval le
carnaval c'est le moment sans doute où
les foules ou les bases instincts sont
les points forts
or dirait mon chéri 20 lots vous n'allez
pas venir vous seriez pour interdire les
carnavals mais gens s'y amuse même s'il
ya des excès donc excès oui interdire
aux ces étudiants de se retrouver pour
former un sorte une sorte de groupe pour
se sentir ensemble gérez vous dire que
le bizutage c'est le carnaval à la
portée des caniches parce que le
carnaval c'est une grande tradition en
effet c'est la permission donnée à tout
le monde absolument d'être accusé ment
mais c'est au détriment du voisin passe
par le carnaval est triste mais en
général avec l'acquiescement des gens
c'est pas une violence gratuite exercées
sur des gens pendant les images qu'on
voit des visites à ses débuts de tâches
est absolument aïssa le glissement de
mai de répugnant parce que c'est en
effet de dire écoutez pendant trois
jours ou deux jours un jour vous avez
permission de libérer tous vos instincts
non cléricaux elle non je je continue
développer d'arguments je pense que
c'est une façon de faire perdurer les
traditions de se sentir bien ensemble
d'avoir l'impression ce que vous dites
r6 y avoir la pression elle est intégrée
à la france le sait bien non on sait
qu'ils nous regardent le savent bien il
réclame vous êtes malheureusement non
c'est ce qui va se passer
vous allez faire un peu plus parce que
vous n'avez pas du tout
alors qu'il reste ou secondaire i voilà
simplement eric revel qui lui même ne se
comporterait jamais comme ça mais c'est
seulement un week end d'intégration ou
le voir garder le bateau loin bien rhône
pour les autres la liberté de voilà deux
de la libérale d'humilier non la liberté
de celui qui humiliait n'existe pas en
tout cas ce qu'on a retenu moi ce que
j'ai retenu de ce débat c'est que dès
qu'un carnaval hier eric revel dedans
ils adorent ça sert d'avoir des battus
[Applaudissements]